So what I call it means like, Hey, so actually right now, um, I'm grocery shopping with my family.
So we'll do this a little bit later. Okay. I'm like, okay, that's fine. Cool. Hour and a half later,
I call them and nothing. I call them again, like 30 minutes later, nothing and nothing. So,
so at that point, do I just move on to the next person? No. So here's what you need to do. Um,
that's kind of like, cause you kind of got that scent sounds like when you were talking to him,
right? And you kind of tell this kind of a yes, man, he's getting, he's nice, sick. He probably
wouldn't do something to offend you. Kind of a guy like really soft spoken. If I get a guy
like that, because you could bulldog the shit out of those guys, but at the end of the day,
they're not going to give you their credit card. So what I do is I I'm like, Hey, can I,
I can call you back later. I got a job. It's hot. They need a tree removal. I can call you back,
but I also don't want to waste my time or your time. If I call you back, are you going to pick
up or is this just the, this is the no, like it's a soft no. I'll, I'll literally say that because
if not, that guy might not even be following you. And now you're going to be like, Oh, I got somebody,
I got somebody. And you're going to be thinking, Oh, we're good, but you're not. So I would ask
right there and then get your answer. And a lot of times that pullback, they're like, Oh, okay,
this is different. This guy is actually like a real person, not a robot. And, and you'll get them
to answer right there. So that's what I would have done different. I would still keep hitting them.
Maybe like if the lead comes in, do a screenshot, blur out the number. Hey, I got this lead. I want
to send it to you. Can you give me a call? Um, but I, I wouldn't chase them too much. I would just
do, I'd be try some different angles.